[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS LATTNER: Hi, everyone.
I'm Chris.
And this is Brennan.
And we're super excited to
tell you about a new approach
to machine learning.
So here in the
TensorFlow team, it
is our jobs to push
the state of the art
in machine learning forward.
And we've learned a lot
over the last few years
with deep learning.
And we've incorporated most
of that all into TensorFlow 2.
And we're really
excited about it.
But, here, we're looking
a little bit further
beyond TensorFlow 2.
And what do I mean by further?
Well, eager mode makes it really
easy to train a dynamic model.
But deploying it still requires
you take that and then write
a bunch of C++ code
to help drive it.
And that could be better.
Similarly, some researchers are
interested in taking machine
learning models and integrating
them into larger applications.
That also often requires
writing C++ code.
We always want more flexible and
expressive autodifferentiation
mechanisms.
And one of things
we're excited about
is being able to define
reusable types that
then can be put into
new places and used
with automatic differentiation.
And we always love improving
your developer workflow.
We want to make
you more productive
by taking errors in your
code and bringing them
to your source and also by just
improving your iteration time.
Now, what we're really
trying to do here
is lift TensorFlow to
entirely new heights.
And to do that, we need
to be able to innovate
at all levels of the stack.
This includes the
compiler and the language.
And that's what Swift for
TensorFlow is all about.
We think that applying new
solutions to old problems
can help push machine learning
even further than before.
Well, let's jump into some code.
So first, what is Swift?
Swift is a modern and
cross-platform programming
language that's designed to
be easy to learn and use.
Swift uses types.
And types are great,
because they can
help you catch errors earlier.
And also, they encourage
good API design.
Now, Swift uses type inference,
so it's really easy to use
and very elegant.
But it's also open source and
has an open language evolution
process, which allows us
to change the language
and make it better for machine
learning which is really great.
Let's jump into a
more relevant example.
This is how you define a simple
model in Swift for TensorFlow.
As you can see, we're
laying out our layers here.
And then we can find a forward
function, which composes them
together in a linear sequence.
You've probably noticed that
this looks a lot like Keras.
That's no accident, of course.
We want you to be able to
take what you know about Keras
and bring it forward
into this world as well.
Now, once we have a simple
model, let's train it.
How do we do that?
All we have to is
instantiate our model,
pick an optimizer and
some random input data,
and then pick a training loop.
And, here, we'll
write it by hand.
One of the reasons we
like writing by hand
is that it gives you
the maximum flexibility
to play with different
kinds of constructs.
And you can do whatever you
want, which is really great.
But some of the major advantages
of Swift for TensorFlow
are the workflow.
And so instead of telling you
about it, what do you think,
Brennan, should be show them?
BRENNAN SAETA: Let's do it.
All right, the team has
thought long and hard
about what's the easiest way
for people to get started
using Swift for TensorFlow.
And what could be easier than
just opening up a browser tab?
This is Google Colab,
hosted Jupyter notebooks.
And it comes with Swift for
TensorFlow built right in.
Let's see it in action.
Here is the layer
model, the model
that Chris just showed you
a couple of slides ago.
And we're going to run it
using some random training
data right here in the browser.
So we're going to
instantiate the model.
We're going to use the
stochastic gradient descent SGD
optimizer.
And here we go.
We have now just
trained a model using
Swift for TensorFlow in our
browser on some training data
right here.
Now, we can see the training
loss is decreasing over time.
So that's great.
But if you're ever like me
and whenever I try and use
machine learning
in any application,
I start with a simple model.
And I've got to iterate.
I've got to tweak the
model to make it fit better
to the task at hand.
So since we're trying to
show you the workflow,
let's actually edit this model.
Let's make it more accurate.
So here we are.
Now, let's think a
little for a moment.
What changes do we want
to make to our model?
Well, this is deep
learning after all.
So the answer is always
to go deeper, right?
But you may have been following
the recent literature in state
of the art in that not
just sequential layers,
but skip connections
or residual connections
are a really good idea to
make sure your model continues
to train effectively.
So let's go through and
actually add an extra layer
to our model.
Let's add some skip connections.
And we're going to do it all
right now in under 90 seconds.
Are you ready?
All right, here we go.
So the first thing
that we want to do
is we need to define
our additional layer.
So we're going to fill
in this dense layer.
Whoops.
Flow.
And one thing you
can see is that we're
using Tab autocomplete
to help fill
in code as we're trying to
develop and modify our model.
Now, we're going to fix up
the shapes right here really
quick, so that the residual
connections will all work.
If I can type properly,
that would go better.
All right, great.
We have now defined our model
with the additional layers.
All we need to do is
modify the forward pass,
so that we add those
skipped connections.
So here we go.
The first thing we
need to do is we
need to store in a
temporary variable
the output of the
flattened layer.
Then we're going to feed the
output of the flattened layer
to our first dense layer.
So dense.applied
to tmp in context.
Now, for the coup de grace,
here is our residual connection.
So dense2.applied to
tmp + tmp2 in context.
Run that.
And, yes, that works.
We have now just
defined a new model
that has residual
connections and is
one additional layer deeper.
Let's see how it does.
So we're going to
reinstantiate our model
and rerun the training loop.
And if you recall from the
loss that we saw before,
this one is now
substantially lower.
This is great.
This is an example of what
it's like to use Swift
for TensorFlow to develop and
iterate as you apply models
to applications and challenges.
But Swift for TensorFlow-- thank
[APPLAUSE]
But Swift for TensorFlow was
designed for researchers.
And researchers often need to
do more than just change models
and change the way the
architecture fits together.
Researchers often need
to define entirely
new abstractions or layers.
And so let's actually
see that live right now.
Let's define a new custom layer.
So let's say we had
the brilliant idea
that we wanted to modify the
standard dense layer that
takes a weights
and biases and we
wanted to add an additional
bias set of parameters, OK?
So we're going to define this
double bias dense layer right
here.
So I'm going to type
this really quickly.
Stand by 15 seconds.
Here we go.
[LAUGHTER]
Woo, all right, that was great.
So let's actually
walk through the codes
that you can see
what's going on.
So the first thing that we have
is we define our parameters.
So these are a W, like our
weights for our neurons,
and B1, bias one, and
B2, our second bias.
We defined an
initializer that takes
an input size and an output
size just like dense does.
We use that to initialize
our parameters.
The forward pass is
very simple to write.
So here's just applied to.
And we just take the matrix
multiplication of input
by our weights, and we
add in our bias terms.
That's it.
We've now just defined a
custom layer right in Colab
in just a few lines of code.
All right, let's
see how it goes.
Here's model two.
And so we're going to use
our double bias dense layer.
And we're going to
instantiate and.
We're going to train it
using, again, our custom
handwritten training loop.
Here's an example of
another way that we
think Swift for TensorFlow
makes your life easier.
Because Swift for TensorFlow can
statically analyze your code,
it can be really helpful to you.
I don't know about you, but I
regularly put typos in my code.
I don't if you saw
me typing earlier.
And Swift for TensorFlow here
is helping you out, right?
It's saying, look, you
mistyped softmaxCrossEntropy.
This should be labels, OK?
All right, so we run it.
We train it.
And our loss isn't as good.
This was not the right idea.
But this is an
example of how easy
it is for researchers to
experiment with new ideas
really easily in
Swift for TensorFlow.
But let's go deeper.
Swift for TensorFlow is, again,
designed for researchers.
And researchers need to be able
to customize everything, right?
That's the whole
point of research.
And so let's show
an example of how
to customize something other
than just a model or a layer.
So you may have heard that large
GPU clusters or TPU super pods
are, like, delivering massive
breakthroughs in research
and advancing the state of the
art in certain applications
and domains.
And you may have also
heard that, as you scale up
to effectively utilize these
massive hardware pools,
you need to increase
your batch size.
And so let's say
you're a researcher,
and you want to
try and figure out
what are the best ways to train
deep neural networks at larger
batch sizes.
Well, if you're a
researcher, you probably
can't buy a whole GPU cluster or
rent a whole TPU super pod all
the time for your experiments.
But you often have a
GPU under your desk.
So let's see how we can simulate
running on a super large data
parallel GPU or TPU cluster
on a single machine.
We're going to do it all in a
few lines of code right here.
So here's our custom
training loop.
Well, here's the
standard part, right?
This is 1 to 10 training epics.
And what we're going to do
is, instead of just applying
our model forward once, we
have an additional inner loop,
right?
So we're going to
run our forward pass.
We're going to run our model--
whoops-- four times.
And we're going to take the
gradients for each step.
And we're going to aggregate
them in this grads variable.
OK?
This simulates running on four
independent accelerators, four
GPUs or four TPUs in a
data parallel fashion
on a batch that's actually
four times as large
as what we actually run.
We're going to then
use our optimizer
to update our model along
these aggregated gradients,
again simulating a data parallel
synchronous training process.
That's it.
That's all there is to it.
We're really excited by
this sort of flexibility
and capabilities that
Swift for TensorFlow
brings to researchers.
Back over to you, Chris.
CHRIS LATTNER: Thanks, Brennan.
[APPLAUSE]
So I think that the focus on
catching errors early and also
productivity enhancements
like code completion
can help you in a lot of ways.
And it's not just about, like,
automating typing of code.
But it can also be
about discovery of APIs.
So another thing that's really
cool about Swift as a language
is that it has really good
interoperability with C code.
And so in Swift, you
can literally just
import a C header file
and call symbols directly
from C without wrappers,
without boilerplate or anything
involved.
It just works.
So we've taken this approach.
In the TensorFlow team,
we've taken this approach
and brought it to
the world of Python.
And one of the cool
things about this
is that that allows you to
combine the power of Swift
for TensorFlow with all the
advantages of the Python
ecosystem.
How about we take a look?
BRENNAN SAETA: Thanks, Chris.
The Python data
science ecosystem
is incredibly
powerful and vibrant.
And we wanted to make
sure that, as you start
using Swift for
TensorFlow, you didn't
miss all your favorite
libraries and utilities that you
were used to.
And so we've built a seamless
Python interoperability
capability to Swift
for TensorFlow.
And let's see how it
works in the context
of my favorite Python data
science library, NumPy.
So the first thing
you need to do
is import TensorFlow
and import Python.
And once you do that, that
defines this Python object
that allows you to import
arbitrary Python libraries.
So here we import pyplot
from the matplotlib library
and NumPy.
And we assign it to np, OK?
After that, we can just use np
just as if we were in Python.
So, here, we call linspace.
We're going to call
sine and cosine.
And we're going to pass
those values to pyplot.
When we run the cell, it just
works exactly as you'd expect.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Now, this sort of kind of
looks like the Python code
you're used to writing, but
this is actually pure Swift.
It just works seamlessly.
But this is maybe a
bit of a toy example.
So let's see this a little
bit more in context.
OpenAI has done a lot
of work in the area
of reinforcement learning.
And in order to help
that along, they
developed a Python
library called OpenAI Gym.
Gym contains a collection
of environments
that are very useful
when you're trying
to train a reinforcement
learning agent
across a variety of
different challenges.
Let's use OpenAI Gym to train
a reinforcement learning
agent in Swift for TensorFlow
right now our browsers.
So the first thing we need to
do is we need to import Gym.
We're going to define a
few hyperparameters here.
And, now, we define
our neural network.
In this case,
we're going to pick
a simple two-layer
dense network.
And it's just a
sequential model, OK?
After that, we have
some helper code
to filter out bad or short
episodes and whatnot.
But here's the real meat of it.
We're going to use
Gym to instantiate
the CartPole v0 environment.
So that's our env.
We're going to then
instantiate our network right
here and our optimizer.
And here's our training loop.
There we go.
So we're going to get
a bunch of episodes.
We're going to run our
model, get the gradients.
And we're going to apply
those to our optimizer.
And we're going to record the
mean rewards as we train, OK?
It's all very simple,
straightforward Swift.
And here you can see us training
a Swift for TensorFlow model
in an OpenAI Gym environment
using the Python bridge,
totally seamless.
And of course,
afterwards, you can
keep track of the
parameters of the rewards.
In this case, we're going
to plot the mean rewards
as the model trained using
Python NumPy, totally seamless.
You can get started using
Swift for TensorFlow using
all the libraries
you know and love
and take advantage of
what Swift for TensorFlow
brings to the table.
Back over to you, Chris.
CHRIS LATTNER: Thanks, Brennan.
So one of the things that
I love about this is it's
not just about being
able to leverage
big important
libraries like NumPy.
We're working on the ability to
integrate Swift for TensorFlow
and Python for
TensorFlow code together,
which we think will
provide a nice transition
path to make you able to
incrementally move code
from one world to the other.
Now, I think it's fair
to say that calculus
is an integral part
of machine learning.
[LAUGHTER]
And we think that
differentiable programming
is so important that we've built
it right into the language.
This has a number
of huge advantages,
including enabling more
flexible and custom work
with differentiables,
with derivatives.
And we think this
is really cool.
So I'd like to take a look.
BRENNAN SAETA: So
we've been using
Swift for TensorFlow's
differential programming
capabilities throughout
all of our demos so far.
But let's really break it
down and see what's going on
at a fundamental level.
So here we define
my function that
takes two doubles and returns a
double based on some products,
and sums, and quotients.
If we want Swift for TensorFlow
to automatically compute
the derivative for us, we just
annotate it at differential.
Swift for TensorFlow will
then derive the derivative
for this function right
when we run the cell.
To use this autogenerated
derivative, use gradient.
So gradient takes two things.
It takes a closure to evaluate
and a point that you want
to evaluate your closure at.
So here we go.
This is what it is to take
the derivative of a function
at a particular point.
So we can change it surround.
This one's my
favorite tasty number.
And that works nicely.
Now, one thing to
note, we've just
been taking the partial
derivatives of my function
with respect to a.
But, of course, you can
take the partial derivatives
and get a full gradient
of my function, like so.
Often with neural
networks, however, you
want to get not just the
gradients for your network
as you're trying to train it
and optimize your loss function.
You often want what the
network predicted, right?
This is really useful to compute
accuracy or other debugging
sort of information.
And for that you can
use value with gradient.
And that returns
a tuple containing
both the value and the
gradient, shockingly enough.
Now, one thing to
note, in Swift,
tuples can actually
have named parameters.
They aren't just ordered.
And so you can actually see that
it prints out really nicely.
And you can access values.
We think this is, again, another
nice little thing that helps
makes writing and debugging
code and, more importantly,
reading it and understanding
it later a little bit easier.
But the one thing that
I want to call out
is that throughout this we've
been using just normal types.
These aren't tensor
of something.
It's just plain old double.
This is because
automatic differentiation
is built right into the language
in Swift for TensorFlow.
It makes it really easy
to express your thoughts
very clearly.
But even though it's
built into the language,
we've actually worked
very hard to make sure
that automatic differentiation
is totally flexible so that you
can customize it to
whatever it needs you have.
And instead of telling you
about that, let's show you.
So let's say you want to
define an algebra in 2D space.
Well, you're certainly going
to need a point data type.
So here we define a point
struct with x and y.
And we just market
differentiable.
We can define helper functions
on it like dot or other helper
functions.
And Swift for TensorFlow, when
you try and use your code,
will often
automatically infer when
you need gradients to be
automatically computed
for you by the compiler.
But often, it's a good idea
to document your intentions.
And so you can annotate
your helper functions
as @differentiable.
The other reason why
we recommend doing this
is because this
helps catch errors.
So here, Swift for
TensorFlow is actually
telling you that, hey, you can
only differentiate functions
that return values that
conform to differentiable.
But int doesn't conform
to differentiable, right?
What this is telling you
is that my helper function
returns an int.
And int is all about taking
infinitesimally small steps
as you optimize and
take gradients, right?
And integers just
are very discrete.
And so Swift for TensorFlow
is helping to catch errors,
you know, right when you
write the code very easily
and tell you what's going on.
So the solution,
of course, is just
to not mark that
as @differentiable.
The cell runs just fine.
But let's say we also wanted to
go beyond just defining the dot
product.
Let's say we also wanted to
define the magnitude helper
function.
That is the magnitude of the
vector defined by the origin
to the point in question.
So to do that, we can
use the distance formula
if you're going to do
Euclidean distance.
And we can define an extension
on point that does this.
But we're going to
pretend for a moment
that Swift doesn't include
a square root function,
because I want a
good excuse for you
to see the interoperability
with C, OK?
So we're actually going to use
C's square root function that
operates on doubles, OK?
So based on the definition
of Euclidean distance,
we can define the magnitude.
And it totally just--
no, it doesn't quite work.
OK.
Let's see what's going on.
So we wanted magnitude
to be differentiable.
And it's saying that you can't
differentiate the square root
function, because this is an
external function that hasn't
been marked as differentiable.
OK.
What's that saying?
Well, the square root,
it's a C function.
It was compiled
by the C compiler.
And as of today, the C
compiler can't automatically
compute derivatives for you.
So Swift for TensorFlow
is saying like, hey, this
isn't going to work.
This is excellent, because
it gives me a great excuse
to show you how to
write custom gradients.
All right, so here we
define a wrapper function,
mySqrt square root,
that just calls down
in the forward pass to the
C square root function.
In the backwards pass,
we take our double
and we return a
tuple of two values.
Rather, the first
element in the tuple
is the normal value
in the forward pass.
And the second is
a pullback closure.
And this is where you
define the backwards pass
capturing whatever values you
need from the forward pass.
OK?
So we're going to run that.
We're going to go back up to
our definition of magnitude
and change it from square
root to my square root,
rerun the cell, and it works.
We've now defined
point and two methods
on it, dot and magnitude.
And we can now combine
these in arbitrary
other silly
differentiable functions.
So, here, I've defined
the silly function.
And we've marked it
as differentiable.
And we're going to
take two points.
We're also going to
take a double, right?
You can mix and match
differentiable data types
totally fluidly.
We're going to return
double, and we're
going to take magnitudes
and do dot products.
It's a silly function after all.
And we can then use it, compute
the gradient of this function
at arbitrary data points.
Just like you'd expect, you can
get the value of the function,
get full gradients in addition
to partial derivatives
with respect to
individual values.
That's been a quick
run through of how
to use customization, custom
gradients, custom data
types with a language integrated
automatic differentiation built
into Swift for TensorFlow.
But let's go one step further.
Let's put all this
together and show
how you can write
your own debuggers
as an example of how this
power is all in your hands.
So often when you're
debugging models,
you often want to be
able to see the gradients
at different points
within your model.
And so here, we can just
define in regular Swift code
a gradient debugger.
Now, it's going to
take as input a double.
And it's going to return
it just like normal
for the forward pass, right?
It's an identity function.
On the backwards pass, we're
going to get the gradient.
We're going to
print the gradient.
And then we're
going to return it.
So we're just passing it
through just printing it out.
Now that we've defined this
gradient debugger ourselves,
we can use it in
our silly function
to see what's going on
as we take derivatives.
So gradient debugger,
there we go.
We can rerun that.
And when we take the gradients,
we can now see that for that
point in the silly function of
a dot b, the gradient is 3.80.
That's been a brief tour through
how automatic differentiation
works in Swift for TensorFlow
and how it's customizable
so that you can harness the
power in whatever abstractions
or systems you need to build.
Back over to you, Chris.
CHRIS LATTNER: Thanks, Brennan.
[APPLAUSE]
So the funny thing
about all this
is that the algorithms
that we're building on
were defined back in the 1970s.
And so it really took
language integration
to be able to bring
these things forward
into the world of
machine learning.
There's a tremendous
amount of depth here.
And I'm really excited to see
what you all can do with it.
And we think that this is going
to enable new kinds of research
which we're very excited about.
There's also a ton of depth.
And if you're interested
in learning more,
we have a bunch of
detailed design documents
available online.
Let's talk about
performance a little bit.
Now, Swift is fast.
And this comes from a number of
different things, one of which
is that the language itself
has really good low level
performance.
There's also no GIL to get
in the way of concurrency.
Swift for TensorFlow also
has some advanced compiler
techniques to automatically
identify graphs for you
and extract them.
So you don't have
to think about that.
The consequence of
all this together
is that we think
Swift has the world's
most advanced eager mode.
Now, you may not care that
much about performance.
You may wonder, like, why
do we care about this stuff?
Well, we're seeing
various trends
in the industry where people
are defining neural nets
and then want to integrate them
into other larger applications.
And typically what this requires
is this requires you to export
graphs and then write a
bunch of C++ code to load
and orchestrate them
in various ways.
So let's take a look
at an example of this.
AlphaGo Zero is
really impressive work
that combines three major
classes of techniques.
Of course, you have deep
learning on the one hand.
But it also drives it through
Monte Carlo tracers to actually
find and evaluate these spaces.
And then it runs them
at scale on industry
leading TPU accelerators.
And so it's the combination
of all three of these things
that make AlphaGo Zero possible.
Now, this is possible today.
And if you're an advanced
team like DeepMind,
you can totally do this.
But it's much more
difficult than it should be.
And we think that breaking
down barriers like this
can lead to new
breakthroughs in science.
And we think that this is what
can drive progress forward.
So instead of talking about
it again, let's take a look.
BRENNAN SAETA: MiniGo
is an open source go
player inspired by DeepMind's
AlphaGo Zero project.
It's available on GitHub.
And you can certainly
check out the code.
And I encourage you to.
They're also going to be here.
And they have some other
presentations tomorrow.
But the MiniGo project,
when they started out,
they were getting everything
in normal TensorFlow.
And it was working
great until they
started trying to run at scale
on large clusters of TPUs.
There, they ran into performance
problems and had to rewrite
things like Monte Carlo tree
search into C++ in order
to effectively utilize
modern accelerators.
Here, we've reimplemented
Monte Carlo tree
search and the rest of the
MiniGo self-play in pure Swift.
And we're going to let you see
it running right here in Colab.
So here we define
a helper function
where we take in a
game configuration
and a couple of participants.
These are our white
and black players.
And we're going to
run, basically, play
the game until we have
a winner or loser.
And so let's actually run this.
Here, we define a
game configuration.
We're going to play between a
Monte Carlo tree search powered
by neural networks versus
just a random player just
to see how easy it is
to flip back and forth
or mix and match
between deep learning
and other arbitrary
machine learning algorithms
right here in Swift.
So here you go.
You can see them playing white,
black, playing different moves
back and forth.
And it just goes.
We think that Swift for
TensorFlow is going to unlock
whole new classes of
algorithms and research,
because of how easy it is to do
everything in one language with
no barriers, no having to
rewrite things into C++.
Back over to you, Chris.
CHRIS LATTNER: Thank, Brennan.
The cool thing about
this, of course,
is that you can
actually do something
like this in a workbook,
which is pretty phenomenal.
And we've seen many different
families of new techniques
that can be combined together
and fused in different ways.
And bringing this to
more people we think
will lead to new kinds
of interesting research.
Now, our work on
usability and design
is not just about
high-end researchers.
So we love them,
but Swift is also
widely used to teach new
programmers how to code.
And education is very
close to our hearts.
And so I'm very excited to
announce a collaboration
that we're embarking on with
none other than Jeremy Howard.
But instead of
talking about this,
I'd rather have Jeremy
speak about it now.
JEREMY HOWARD: At
Fast.AI, we're always
looking to push the
boundaries of what's
possible with deep
learning, especially
pushing to make recent
advances more accessible.
We've been involved with
setting image net speed
records at a cost of just $25
and building the world's best
document classifier.
Hundreds of thousands
have become deep learning
practitioners
through our courses
and are producing state of the
art results with our library.
We think that with
Swift for TensorFlow,
we can go even further.
So we're announcing today that
our next course will include
a big Swift component
co-taught by someone
that knows Swift pretty well.
BRENNAN SAETA: Chris,
I think he means you.
CHRIS LATTNER: Yeah,
we'll see how this goes.
So I'm super excited
to be able to help
teach the next
generation of learners.
But I'm also really
excited that Jeremy
will be bringing his
expertise in API design
and helping us
shape the high level
APIs in Swift for TensorFlow.
So we've talked
about many things.
But the most important
part is Swift
for TensorFlow is really
TensorFlow at its core.
And we think this
is super important,
because we've worked really hard
to make sure that it integrates
with all the things going on
in the big TensorFlow family.
And we're very
excited about that.
Now, you may be wondering
where you could get this.
So Swift for TensorFlow
is open source.
You can find out
it on GitHub now.
And you can join our community.
It also works great in
Colab as you've seen today.
We have tutorials.
We have examples.
And all the demos you saw
today are available now
in Colab, which is great.
We've also released
our 0.2 release, which
includes all the
basic infrastructure
and underlying technology to
power these demos and examples.
And we're actively working
on high level APIs right now.
So this is not
ready for production
yet as you could guess.
But we're very excited
about shaping this future,
building this out, exploring
this new programming model.
And this is a great opportunity
for advanced researchers
to get involved and help shape
the future of this platform.
So we'd love it for you
to try it out and let
us know what you think.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]